[Music]
hi mystery recapped here today i am
going to explain a teen comedy film
called wild child
spoilers ahead watch out and take care
the story centers around a spoiled
teenage girl named poppy moore living in
malibu with her widowed father and
little sister poppy's mother died in a
car crash long ago and ever since her
relationship with her father jerry
hasn't been the same she hates him for
dating women who are not her mother when
his current girlfriend is about to move
in with them poppy is furious she
invites her friends and makes them
destroy the woman's belongings that are
being moved into the house it is not the
first time she has pulled a prank like
this jerry is sick and tired of her
making his life more difficult till now
he has been excusing her considering
that she just missed her mother but now
that poppy has crossed a line he wants
to send her to a boarding school in
england at first she retaliates but
jerry is determined to discipline her in
the right way at night poppy and her
little sister molly talk about her
upcoming life in england poppy claims
she is relieved people in england at
least speak american molly realizes how
out of proportion her sister is to the
real world she hopes that poppy will
learn something from her stay the next
day poppy's best friend ruby helps her
pack and wishes her luck with england's
weather she also promises to take care
of poppy's boyfriend roddy when she is
away suss in the following scene jerry
and poppy arrive at the boarding school
in the countryside in england they are
welcomed by the school's headmistress
mrs kingsley who promises to discipline
poppy in no time all other students are
stunned to see her in her over-the-top
designer outfit the head girl of the
school harriet also lands her eyes on
her and greets her with a handshake she
is an egocentric and proud student who
thinks she runs the school when poppy
refuses to respect her she is determined
to teach her a lesson poppy finally bids
farewell to her father and walks inside
the school she soon finds out she has to
share a bedroom with four other girls
kate josie kiki and drippy she bluntly
asks them to get out because she wants
to be left alone but the girls only
laugh at her then she is told that the
girls are only allowed to use their
phones on the weekend but poppy refuses
to do so a while later the hostile's
matron comes to seize their phones for
the week when poppy talks to her
sarcastically she along with the other
girls get detention as punishment poppy
tries using her old ways by bribing the
matron but it only gets her in more
trouble on her first day of school she
modifies the school uniform to fit her
taste she wears high heels a tight skirt
and a cropped blazer unlike the other
girls her roommates warn her that it
might get her in trouble but poppy as
always doesn't care then she is told
about the school's prefect team whose
leader is the head girl harriet she has
a crush on the school's most popular
bachelor and the headmistress's son
named freddy one of the important rules
in the school is that no girl is allowed
to fraternize with any boys especially
not freddie the headmistress is strictly
against her son dating anyone at night
before bedtime the girls ask poppy how
many guys she has slept with on hearing
the long list they're shocked because
they have been in the all-girls hostel
since they were kids and have no
experience with boys whatsoever later
the matron brings poppy a proper set of
uniforms to wear from the next day poppy
huffs at her and pretends to go to sleep
but right after the matron leaves she
goes to the computer room to email her
best friend ruby about everything
happening in her life while she is at it
she notices someone walking outside the
room on checking she finds drippy in the
freezer having a late night snack just
then a fire drill takes place and poppy
is stuck in the hallways in order to not
get caught she climbs on the roof and
enters a bathroom the bathroom turns out
to be freddy's who tells her the way out
and promises to keep her visit a secret
the following day poppy is taken into
the school's lacrosse team the diva in
her is horrified by girls running around
covered in sweat but when the head girl
harriet challenges her to a one-on-one
match she accepts it they launch at each
other but instead of hitting the ball
they start to fist fight harriet stops
only when freddie's car passes by she is
smitten with him and hence is horrified
when he greets poppy a good morning
after he drives off poppy makes fun of
her for being in love with him harriet
runs to her dorm room which consists of
several pictures of freddy proving her
obsession with him she panics about how
he knew poppy's name but comes to the
conclusion that he was just trying to
hide his love for her by talking to a
random girl a while later poppy is
called by the headmistress who is
disappointed at her for starting a fight
she knows that poppy is not a bad person
and hopes that she will do better in
school from now on poppy is amazed by
the headmistress's expectations for the
first time after her mother's death
someone has shown faith in her later
that day harriet is sitting in her room
when she notices poppy sitting right
below the window she makes her minion
dump a bucket of water on her and
pretends like she didn't know someone
was downstairs poppy has to rush to her
room shivering she misses her friends
from back home and is feeling homesick
one of her roommates named kate notices
this and offers poppy a jumper for her
cold poppy feels at home with kate and
tells her about her mother's death that
happened five years ago the two talk
about their past and form a bond that
poppy had never thought she would make
with someone from school kate also gives
her a secret phone so she can call her
friends in america pompey calls ruby who
surprise surprise turns out to be
sleeping with poppy's boyfriend roddy
they fake being concerned for her and
end the call right after ruby makes fun
of poppy's appearance and continues
making out with her boyfriend that night
poppy's roommates decide to help her get
expelled from school which is the only
way she can get back to america since
she so desperately wants to go home they
feel sympathetic and want to help poppy
is overwhelmed by the love they show to
her even though she has been nothing but
rude starting the next day they play a
plethora of pranks dying the swimming
pool's water red prank calling harriet
and spreading rumors about their
teachers making out in the school for
the last one poppy gets into trouble she
is called to the headmistress's office
but is let go after a simple warning the
girls register that the headmistress is
letting poppy off the hook because she
is jerry's daughter hence they will have
to do something out of the ordinary to
get her in real trouble when they are in
the bath one day they think of a
brilliant idea one thing the
headmistress hates is her son getting
close to any girls from the school this
means if poppy made out with him she is
bound to be expelled the next day is the
themed dance party where the people from
the boys school will also come although
the party is pride and prejudice themed
poppy and her group decide to do
something extra they go to the town to
shop for the big day and have a lot of
fun poppy also changes her hair color to
brunette which makes her look exactly
like her mother they secretly steal
liquor from a shop planning to get
wasted at the party the following
evening everything is going well the
students are properly dressed especially
harriet who is dressed as elizabeth she
bores freddy by speaking to him in lines
from the book the party is then
interrupted by poppy and her group
making a grand entrance in their short
modern dresses harriet is horrified but
the same cannot be said for freddy he
seems to be attracted to poppy the night
turns into a nightmare for the head girl
when freddy and poppy dance together she
quickly changes the song to an upbeat
one so people would dance individually
her plan works but then poppy dances
alone and steals the show later she and
freddie go outside for some alone time
some poppy playtime harriet sends her
minions to keep an eye on them as the
two talk poppy realizes freddie is quite
an interesting man who actually cares
about people he leans in to kiss her but
the minions interrupt them the girls
decide not to tell harriet about this
because she will make their life
miserable trying to separate freddie and
poppy poppy then returns to her friends
who are having the time of their lives
with the boys as they talk she confesses
that she has never been intimate with
anyone and used to be ashamed of it back
home hence she lied to them at first but
now she feels like she can tell them
anything without fear of being judged
she also reveals that she might actually
like freddy not just for the purpose of
the prank the next day poppy is invited
to lacrosse after drippy gets sick she
discovers her talent for the game and
the team wins for the first time because
of her the next day in the morning
assembly the headmistress announces that
their junior lacrosse team has been
selected to play in the inter-school
competition for the first time in over a
decade she asks the participants to talk
to harriet if they have any concerns but
then she corrects herself because the
students should now go to poppy instead
of harriet harriet glows red in anger at
the announcement
starting the next day poppy whips the
school's team into shape getting them
into the finals of the competition then
one day she is invited on a date by
freddie before going she's on a computer
sending emails to her friends back home
she forgets to log off resulting in
someone else mishandling her email
freddy and poppy go on a date and talk
about different things they discover
they have a lot in common and start to
fall for each other on returning to her
room poppy finds her friends reading an
email exposing that she thinks of them
as losers the group assumes that the
email was sent by her and is furious she
tries explaining but the girls are so
hurt that they refuse to listen when
poppy goes to freddie to talk she finds
out that he has also received a similar
email exposing that she is only using
him to get expelled with no one else to
turn to poppy sneaks down to the cook's
room and calls ruby she initially
pretends to be interested in what poppy
is talking about but then accidentally
reveals how much she dislikes her poppy
feels the lowest she has ever been she
gets lost in her thoughts and starts
playing with her lighter which
accidentally sets a curtain on fire she
immediately puts it out and runs outside
after hearing footsteps approaching when
she is back in her room she looks out
her window to see the fire that she
thought was put out has actually spread
she quickly wakes everyone up but finds
out that drippy is missing on realizing
that she might have snuck out for a late
night snack poppy goes to save her with
the firefighter's help they managed to
get her out safely when the fire is
extinguished freddy finds poppy's
lighter in the mess and assumes she was
the one who lit the fire to get expelled
he refuses to hear any explanation and
gives the lighter back to her later that
day poppy decides to do one right thing
and takes the blame for the fire the
headmistress is disappointed in her but
she acknowledges the fact that poppy
decided to be truthful she declares that
a hearing will be held at the honor
court to decide what they should do next
in the following scene poppy finds a
portrait of her late mother on the 1976
lacrosse team and begins to cry upon
realizing her mother attended the same
school while she waits for the honor
court hearing freddie finds and is
convinced the fire was just an accident
at the same time drippy and the group
matched the time that the email was sent
and realized someone had tried to
sabotage their friendship with poppy at
the hearing poppy gives her testimony
harriet interrupts her several times and
tells her how horrible of a person she
is to put everyone's lives in danger
when everyone else speaks in poppy's
favor she panics and accidentally
mentions the lighter no one had ever
said anything about the lighter and no
students other than freddie knew about
it this proves that harriet was the one
who lit the curtains on fire after poppy
ran away she confesses that she did it
but tries to rationalize it as finishing
what poppy started in the end poppy is
let free without any charges while
harriet is expelled in the last scene
jerry comes to visit his daughter and
watches the lacrosse finals game poppy's
dramatic change in both appearance and
attitude surprises him they win the
match thanks to her leadership
the father and daughter reunite after
the game and hug
subscribe for more videos like this turn
on notifications and leave a like to
help the channel out thank you for
watching